Peggy's 16
social play appeals to both the pro
player and the novice part of that is
the progression that we've put through
the game from a simple dash to a complex
dash it's the time trials in the end
this is a variety of difficulty that
people can make and it's the approach
we've taken to them using our companion
app and website you can customize your
social profile you can look at the
leaderboards for your latest challenges
infinite possibilities of how you want
to compete and when you want to compete
and the player can create challenges
wherever they want to we still have time
trials but instead of actually
specifying the checkpoints ourselves we
actually let players who being a truly
skillful player was something we really
wanted to tap into something we want to
want it to build on and of course we've
created other challenges and other what
we call dashes a dash at its simplest is
a race complexity and depth comes from
discovering the right route for you and
then mastering that from the beginning
to the end in most of our social content
we have a thing called echoes which is a
sort of echo of a previous experience
that someone has had on that race or
that time trial that they've gone on the
visualization of that actually relates
to the beat it's a augmented reality
piece of a lens that faith is wearing at
that time
so the bait is the system runners used
to communicate in game and we've taken
that concept and created our companion
experience app and our website another
social element that we have is the be
telly or the beat location emitter and
is the ability for me as a player to
place a geotag in a sense in a certain
place in the city and then for you to
discover it or find it and it's all up
to you where you want to create this and
how you want it to be played you can
make it easy or you can make it
incredibly difficult if that's what you
want I can't wait to see you what
players will do with it
I'm super proud of the game
it's not only live up to their
expectations but immensely exceeded
certainly is exceeded mine
you